I mean I wasn't a very good waitress
really well why why were you bad well I
mean waitressing is very difficult for
sure and you have to remember a lot of
things it's easy no you want to be very
precise and fast wait can you just
putting the food down yeah no you've got
to put your wallet
and are you keen on the French ladies
I was 22 at the time uh 23. um you know
she taught me a lot I mean amazing and
uh it's difficult
um down there I'm trying to be polite
and sort of you know very discreet at
the same time just say what you want
well her Fanny started there very hairy
they don't do bikini waxes in France
Gordon One Direction was originally made
up of five members yes which member left
the band too easy Simon Cowell
what he's putting a hat on in the water
because he's cold middle of summer he
was minus five
that is too cold it was freezing my even
my Willy went in was right
disappeared that day it's it's been
inward for 40 years
so don't give me that okay all right the
word chef chef
ladies cook okay okay
joke
oh all right
hey hey hey we can bleep out the swayers
but when there's this going around I
can't do anything
well they're either in the gym or
they're cooking yeah they're Great Cooks
bloody good Cooks yeah happy with bloody
yeah buddy yeah we love buddy that's so
much rather just rather bloody than
anything else yeah so uh yeah the
restraint it's got It's hard
did I scare you guys finally an
attractive guest
yes you did scare us I never scream like
that in real life you know I was sorry
I'm in the bedroom
well you would never know but let me ask
you
no I get more fruity than violence
thank you very much indeed
um that looks like piss
have you waxed
if you're dancing right and you've got a
leotard on okay
but you you sat back and cracked
you don't do that do you no I don't know
I thought it's quite common with you and
your friends
you posted this you've started a vegan
roast dinner
um and then Piers Morgan replied oh for
sake Ramsay not you as well this looks
utterly revolting what do you say to
this to peers is critique so Piers
Morgan is now a food critic yeah sure go
on yourself seriously really I told you
I need you to pee so don't you wake
somebody up by doing that
I mean that is not true that is not true
listen you didn't bring your wheelie on
my Force
Ramsay did you or did you not bang your
willy on his foot yes
all right
what do you want to be fit for is there
a goal yeah just to set an example to
the kids oh that's nice and to keep Tana
interested
she was all over me when I lost the
weight your wife unbelievable I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I'm
getting crispy
sorry
[Applause]
your chicken's dry your display of
greens is way too weak and your pasta is
way too tender you should be ashamed of
yourself don't look down when I'm
looking at you at least look them in the
eyes thank you I'd tell you to walk out
of the studio with your head down but I
know you haven't developed the leg
muscles to pull that off so who has been
the most intimidating person that you've
ever cooked for uh oh God I remember
inviting around to down the street ones
to cook for uh Mr Blair Tony Blair and
President Putin oh wow yeah then I
generally did myself thinking
can you imagine if you food poisoning
these two how oh my God
okay
may I
sure no no but please I mean that looks
like a pilot
foreign
now we don't see much of you because
you're so busy in America
there was a very very popular meme came
out of that sketch let's remind
everybody of what we're talking about
what are you an idiot
sandwiches
I just said to the guy I said turn
around we're taking these pigs back I
said Thank you thank you so much it
didn't happen
he ended up playing it so he went over
the end of the story before you clap
yeah sorry I don't want to piss on your
bonfire however
um they I'm learning something new every
second
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
okay this is my interview yeah
thank you
don't you worry about him
come on
some pepper that's really important okay
a few herbs in the cavity as well okay
how many members are in the band BTS
[Music]
come on
uh seven
[Applause]
sometimes fast food is the best food in
the world exactly especially if you
haven't eaten it for like a year Dina
did you like tomato ketchup love
tomatoes I love tomato yeah now the best
tomatoes
on the side if you go to his restaurants
you want to ketchup we can't get Heinz
no you get some [ __ ] he's made
it's not even proper ketchup I say no to
Graham Norton this week because of you
next year you can go and [ __ ] yourself
okay